hi I'm Eric Voss a and fantastic beasts
the crimes of Grindelwald released a new
trailer at comic-con with some
interesting clues it connect the story
even more deeply to the Harry Potter
mythology while still not skimping out
on those beasts either because you know
I'm sure some people watch these movies
for ol klepto duck and leaf head I know
that's not their names but I don't got a
breakdown this trailer frame by frame
for all the interesting Easter eggs and
details you might have missed and
spoiler warning in case any of my
theories or predictions into being right
and real quick before you begin this
video is brought to you by Squarespace
whether you need a domain website or
online store make it with squares face
but more details on that later
okay let's dive into this trailer see
what we can find is revalue I'm scared
cuz that's the Dumbledore everyone
he's scared of something what is this
okay this opening section returns to BAM
Hogwarts back when Newt Scamander was
just a student and Albus Dumbledore was
just a mere professor you're played by
Jude Law this whole class lesson is a
callback to Professor lupins defense
against a dark arts class and the
Prisoner of Azkaban remember when he
taught Harry and the other is the
ridiculous spell to deal with the
Boggart which shape shifts into the
observers greatest fear now of course
Dumbledore wasn't the defense against
the dark arts professor during this time
he taught Transfiguration it was Galatia
merry thoughts who taught the defense
against the dark arts at this period
just don't get too hung up on this the
bog art is still a shapeshifter and a
ridiculous is kind of a Transfiguration
charm so this lesson could fit within
Dumbledore's curriculum - or maybe he's
just filling in for a day or a
Dumbledore's backstory could just be
getting revised in a way that's
important to the plot of the story maybe
he was a da da professor at some point
but he just kind of covered that up in
his past either way guys Jo Rowling
wrote the script for this movie I don't
think it's a huge mistake that we should
get all up in arms about Newton
double-doors relationship is quite
parallel to Harry and lupins notice this
line I'm scared Professor Dumbledore
Harry says this same exact line the
Lupin in Prisoner of Azkaban
I'm scared professor well if you weren't
we see the second part of the scene in
the next section yes you're up next
that's an unusual one what mr. Scamander
fears above everything else is having to
work in an office sir go ahead
ridiculous okay the fact that newts
greatest fear is a desk job it's just
perfectly suited for his adventurous
animal loving spirit but check out the
girl behind him Slytherin colors and
patch that is definitely a young leader
Lestrange newts friend who later gets
with his brother Theseus and she's
probably the character who does
something that gets Newt kicked out of
Hogwarts and we'll probably see what
that is in this movie notice her nervous
expression she's terrified I think we're
about to see that her greatest fear is
something extremely dark something she
does of what the class knowing could be
related to her family which has been
known to be associated with dark wizards
and if this student is someone important
I wouldn't be surprised if all these
kids could be revealed as parents or
grandparents of people we know like this
dude and Gryffindor red and yellow and
oh could be flea maan Potter that's
Harry's grandfather I notice now he has
similar black hair is Harry and James do
though unless they've changed the ages
of characters from the books as we
currently know them I'm not sure if Lee
Montana would have been at Hogwarts
around the same time and one last
interesting detail before I move on
notice the little sound effect that
plays right before a newt cast a spell
ridiculous I don't know about you guys
but I definitely heard a growl there
maybe this means that the image in his
mind of something silly and
non-threatening to transform the bar
guard into is a beast of some kind
something that would be the rest of the
kids in the classroom greatest fear but
something that new too loves let's move
on magic room
[Music]
only in rare souls okay is the trailer
tics into gear we see some shots that we
saw from the first trailer with Mikasa
or Tina Goldstein in front of this
enchanted statue except now we see more
of the clip and that the statue is
moving part of her garment to the side
it's almost as if this statue is
unveiling a hidden entrance on the other
side of the base perhaps this is how one
excesses the French Ministry of Magic
kind of like how that London phone booth
is the entry point for the British
ministry we also see an
over-the-shoulder shot of Claudia Kim's
character who is currently known only as
the maledictis it's actually the name of
a blood curse for this woman it causes
her to gradually transform into an
animal could be the snake woman who we
see advertised on the sign for the
circus there's actually a theory out
there that I'm very interested in this
character could eventually become Nagini
these same snake that Voldemort keeps as
one of his Horcruxes that snake remains
the one Horcrux that we don't really
know the backstory to so I wouldn't be
surprised if it gets revealed in this
movie so this all seems to be taking
place that these circus are canis it's
kind of a freak show where a magical
persons work disguising their abilities
as mere entertainment and over this we
hear the speech by Gellert Grindelwald
played by Johnny Depp which we hear more
of in the next clips go in shadows
[Music]
of the old ways save us no longer ok
this section shows credence bare-bones
Ezra Miller observing a poster for the
circus suggesting he's on the run and
looking for a circus to run away with a
home for other people like him
and after that deluminator shot from the
first trailer we see Grindelwald in
captivity most likely the jail of McHugh
says since remember he got arrested in
New York in the first movie and he
appears paralyzed in this awkward
contortion fluting this could be a
similar spell that Voldemort used on
professor Burbidge at the beginning of
Deathly Hallows which would be a little
ironic considering Burbidge was murdered
because she was a muggle studies teacher
and she believed muggles and wizards
were equal the exact opposite of
Grindelwald views and Grindelwald sounds
terrifyingly convincing as he pronounces
those views to his followers which
number by the hundreds at his side is
vin de rozier another family that later
became Death Eaters notice how she holds
this circular object now at comic-con a
clip was shown of Grindelwald using the
elder one to activate some kind of skull
and yeah looking at it now it definitely
seems like a glowing skull is what a
brassiere is holding here it's still not
clear what the skulls function is but a
similar skull appears at top of the
screenplay cover page for this movie and
many are saying this could be the origin
of the Death Eater symbol of the skull
and the snake hmmm let's move on I take
it you've heard the rumors a vision
that he will rise to dominance over the
Wizarding World
so you're asking me to help hunt him
down
okay we see characters in Paris the main
setting for this movie including
maledictis and Queenie notice this black
cloth that appears to blanket over the
city block this could actually be a
creature from the Harry Potter world
called the left fold also known as a
living shroud it's a dangerous being
that looks like a black cloth half an
inch thick and it eats people the only
protection from it is a Patronus charm
one used to fend off the Mentors there's
also this interesting shot of
Grindelwald looking up through a
translucent version of Creedence his
head and notice how his odd eye is very
pronounced here there's a theory that
others have speculated that this I could
be mad I moody's I you know the one that
can rotate 360 degrees and allowing to
see through anything
that sounds a lot of fun I don't know if
it's true but there could be some kind
of enchantment to this I like maybe it
allows them to see where the deathly
hallows are or maybe it allows them to
just visualize someone wherever they are
or to control them the way Grindelwald
seems to be trying to do with credence
is destructive obscurest power those are
shot and what I last speculated could be
the French ministry with this character
whose name is Mel Essene now it's not
totally clear what those three capped
like beings are quick look at Pottermore
suggests that they could be measles
those are intelligent cat-like creatures
they also have blue eyes diesels have a
knack for spotty and shady characters
which would make these very useful for
an order kind of like canine dogs
sniffing drugs and three black cat
similar creatures would be fitting for a
witch given the cultural association
between black cats and witchcraft and
the number three which dates back to the
three witches of macbeth and we see how
newt gets atop st. Paul's Cathedral in
London up there with Dumbledore
Dumbledore has left one of his gloves
behind a pointing up to him as a kind of
port key which Newt grabs that
transforms stuff up there clever moving
on
I can't move against Grindelwald it has
to be you
in your shoes I'd probably refuse to
there's late that evening it oh come on
okay
this section has the most interesting
shot of this trailer Dumbledore looks in
this mirror but that's not any mirror
that is the mirror of Erised said which
we saw in the Philosopher's Stone it was
source or stone over here in the US he
shows us nothing more or less than the
deepest and most desperate desires of
our hearts so for his deepest desire
Harry saw himself with his parents which
looking back concern his parents our bed
does that make Harry suicidal no no no
it's not that dark now in the book
Dumbledore tells Harry that he sees
himself in the mirror with some nice
socks but now we know the truth of what
Dumbledore sees when he looks in the
mirror of Erised said at least when he's
a younger man he sees his old friend
Gellert Grindelwald now it has been
applied that Dumbledore rid of all not
only admired each other as younger men
but that they shared a deeper romantic
relationship and now we get confirmation
of that this also gives us some new
meanings Dumbledore's dark warning to
Harry and philosopher's stone men have
wasted away in front of it
it does not do to dwell on dreams
interesting so that kind of suggests
that Dumbledore is obsession or at least
his protection of Grindelwald was
something that ate away at him and of
course it partly explains why Dumbledore
says that can't be him who goes against
grandeur wall probably because he can't
bring himself to attack someone he cares
so deeply for or at least someone who
might know his real vulnerabilities
better than other enemies would now
there is a theory out there that the
reason Dumbledore needs newt in
particular to go against Grindelwald is
because it was new to disarmed
Grindelwald at the end of the first
fantastic beast movie when he lasted him
with one of its creatures so even though
Grindelwald definitely still seems to
possess the older one in this movie if
this theory is true the wand wouldn't
cast a killing curse against its true
master the way it couldn't cast a curse
against Harry in Deathly Hallows that
could be interesting Phil I think it's
more likely that there is a deeper
reason to newt having to be the one
perhaps related to the nature of his
character in his knowledge of magical
beasts and where to find them perhaps a
more subtle power that Grindelwald might
overlook once again he's done it before
on to the next clip
[Music]
you underestimate your talents missus
come on
their arrogance is a key to our victory
okay here we see more of those beasts
you all tuned in for klepto duck who's
really called an inn Fleur he's the
mysterious little jerk who steals and
hoards valuables and this shot of Newt
riding a kelpy I'm pretty sure which we
now see is actually in this indoor area
that fills with water perhaps it's
rapidly filling up form a tank that
spilt over in newts Mary Poppins
suitcase there's also a shot of a bunch
of oars marching and what looks like a
row of mausoleums in a cemetery and I
think that's Theseus commander leading
them newts brother
now we've seen other shots that look
like they take place in cemeteries of
past footage and now I'm thinking that
that big cavernous auditorium that
Grindelwald speaks to his followers in
could be a secret massive temple located
underneath this graveyard moving on
muggles are nicer
not disposable
okay this section includes an
interesting cross dissolve between
Dumbledore and Grindelwald
so that briefly the two appear to be
pacing each other again hinting at their
past relationship but also their
destined clash we also seen Newt Tina
and Lidl estranged in that French
Ministry again now they lose themselves
in this grid of rotating columns don't
know what's going on here looks fun and
then there's this shot of blue flames in
the shape of a dragon head as it lashes
down at Jacob and Tina tries to keep it
back now this could be fiend fire
that's the deadly uncontrollable fire
curse that Crabbe used on Harry Ron
Hermione in the Room of Requirement and
Deathly Hallows and then ended up dying
in the unifier was powerful enough to
destroy the Horcrux of Ravenclaw's
diadem though in a movie Harry snapped
it with masculist venom for good measure
that fee and fire took the form of a
snake we also see this kind of
shape-shifting fiend fire used by bull
de mort and order of the Phoenix so the
fact that these blue flames also take
the shape of an animal makes me think
that it's bean fire and actually blue
flames are even hotter than normal
flames so perhaps Grindelwald is using
an even deadlier version of being fire
here and then newt tries to calm this
massive beast and that doesn't look
anything like any beast in the records I
could find I thought maybe a chimera
since its tail looks kind of different
from the rest of it but those legs
definitely don't look like goat legs I'm
thinking this is something new now you
could see newt is holding something on
the end of his wand to get this thing's
attention I just can't make out what it
is really the part I keep looking at are
this thing's teeth
they're super sharp inner rows of teeth
but also for big tusks sticking up out I
don't know the teeth and this thing's
fur color also the straps and chains
around its neck this just kind of
reminds me of the look of the monster
book of monsters from Prisoner of
Azkaban but maybe I'm just seeing things
moving on no two could meet you never
met a monster you couldn't love
treatise
okay here we finally hear Leda Lestrange
say a line and her words perfectly
encapsulated as a character she uses his
general love for all beasts as a
critique that he doesn't have the nerve
to take on a real monster perhaps
referring to Grindelwald she could also
be referring to credence whom we see in
this section with another wizard as the
flat therein explodes and reassembles
itself not sure what's going on here who
this guy is but it's a very cool way to
have a fight and then we see Grindelwald
daring escape which will probably occur
early in the movie now this carriage is
drawn by thestrals those are the mounts
that you can only see if you've seen
death and the last trailer we saw
Grindelwald contained in this carriage
as a prisoner still but Anneliese at the
reins lasting the sides of it and using
lightning to strike down orders that are
trying to pursue him
so either Grindelwald attack the orders
when he was inside the carriage with him
or we turn the tables on them in another
way actually kind of have a loose theory
on that that I'll get to after this clip
mr. Scamander
do you think Dumbledore will move for
him okay so the footage here is a little
confusing we just saw Greenwald sitting
on the carriage and we know that at some
point he was inside of it restrained so
why now do we see him far away from the
carriage he's watching it with the Elder
Wand in hand does this shot take place
after he escapes now he's watching the
carriage crash-and-burn
or is this someone else who's bringing
the Elder Wand to Grindelwald kind of
like r2d2 alley-oop being Luke's
lightsaber to him to help him escape
here's a theory for you maybe the
Grindelwald at the oars having captivity
could be an impostor someone pretending
to be Grindelwald but it's not really
Grindelwald perhaps Vin de rozier
drinking some a glug glug Polyjuice so
then perhaps the real Grindelwald the
one with the Elder Wand shows up to
rescue his companion to freak out all
these oars look I know it sounds crazy
but it would present a nice mirror to
the scene of Deathly Hallows remember
when the order used Polyjuice potion to
transport Harry by a night flight let me
know how wrong I am about this in the
comments and before the title we see one
final shot of Grindelwald with vinda in
the background and that glowing skull
and grinning wall flinging a curse at
Newton Theseus and that brings us to the
final clip ghost no I'm alive but I'm an
alchemist and therefore immortal
oh you're gonna fly man J koalas oh oh
you don't look a day over 375 okay this
is the other big reveal this trailer
Nicolas Flamel he is the Alchemist from
Harry Potter lore who created the
Philosopher's Stone that was the
MacGuffin for the first Harry Potter
book and film well not only used the
Philosopher's Stone to make him in his
wife immortal but immortality isn't what
we expected he's over 600 years old at
this point and very very brittle so
maybe instead of eternal life it sounds
like the Philosopher's Stone just
prolongs death but the fact that Flamel
comes up in the story at all is very
interesting it sounds like the
Philosopher's Stone and immortality have
a role to play and Grindelwald plot we
know the Deathly Hallows are very
important to him so perhaps this whole
movie will just end up being a race to
immortality here's a question don't
leave you guys with do you think Newt is
the euro you're most excited to see in
this movie or would you rather just see
Dumbledore take it over don't get me
wrong I love the character of Newt
Scamander and the way Eddie Redmayne has
played him let's be honest and back
showdown between double doing
Grindelwald is real reads and we're
watching these movies comment down below
if your thoughts are tweeting the idea
of us and following the rockstars on
Twitter for updates on our videos ok as
I mentioned before this video was
brought to you by Squarespace if you
want to set up a super stylish website
fast you can make it with Squarespace
whether it's to set up a business or
showcase some of your creative work or
maybe post a collage of photos showing
your most fantastic beasts and maps of
where to find them I'm just saying the
Wizarding World would really benefit
from using this muggle creative internet
and their wonderful website services
Squarespace has eight new templates in
2018 and they look so nice the best part
is you don't have to know anything about
coding or design they just take care of
all that for you just go to Squarespace
comm for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch go to Squarespace comm
slash new rockstars to get 10% off your
first purchase or click on the link in
the description below and a reminder to
like this video share it around
subscribe to new rock stars for
breakdowns and analysis of all the stuff
that you love and all the big trailers
to drop at comic-con this year thanks
for watching it mister
[Music]